[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'll be fine without me
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalists podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less
my name is Joshua fields Millburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists yes we are welcome to
episode number 39 today today we're
gonna talk about noise let's talk let's
talk about what is noise what do we mean
by noise cuz when you hear that word
noise you hear you think about what you
think about the auditory stimuli but I
think broadly we're gonna talk more
about just all stimuli right like what's
going on in the world around us so it
could be visual noise it can be actual
noise noise noise it can be kinesthetic
noise where you know you're walking
through crowds of people you're at a
concert you're in a busy city or
whatever it can be also this internal
noise you know all of the thoughts and
feelings emotions the internal clutter
or internal noise what we have going on
in our head as well but also what we're
feeling in terms of the rest of our body
the pain can be a particular kind of
noise for me I have I have tinnitus in
my right ear and it's not it's not
really bad like I know some people get
it to where it's just constantly ringing
all the time no matter what but if I'm
in a quiet place just my right ear is
constantly ringing it's just a
a constant Bell in my ear so there's
that kind of noise as well so today I
want to just talk you about talk to you
about stimuli and and noise and what's
going on inside what's going on outside
and how do we how do we calm all of that
how do we sort of turn down the volume
I'm gonna start with there's a excerpt
in our book everything that remains it's
a quick paragraph here
the fifth chapter of everything that
remains is a chapter called strong moves
slow which i think is an appropriate
metaphor for everything we're going to
be talking about today but in june of
2010 i had been simplifying my life for
about six months then it was shortly
after my mother died and my marriage
ended and I've been just exploring
quieting my life but by getting rid of
the excess stuff I took this business
trip to New York City and I was there
for like four days but it felt like much
longer because there was just this
constant noise and so this is a brief
excerpt talking about the noise all
around us it had been quiet on the
subway what a nice surprise
of course I didn't comprehend the
silence until now after already exiting
the J train I'm approaching Times Square
swimming vigorously against the stream
of people and the spill of electric
light
everything seems caffeinated I am here
beneath the Hal of the world the pulse
of a city dead inside and yet all this
noise is unable to wake the dead heads
tilt downward faces lost and glowing
screens technology turning people into
zombies the lights ripple in the High
Noon heat bending and flickering and
dancing all around me overwhelming and
unforgiving sucking the polluted oxygen
from the air
spitting fluorescent fumes a rainbow of
glow that rivals the Sun in the cerebral
sky overhead
so when I was there I remember going to
Times Square
walking to Times Square through all that
and it was just overwhelming and I think
we're at a place now where noise has
become the default setting in our lives
and and so when we're thinking about how
do we quiet that we're really talking
about resetting our default setting most
of the time and so let's answer some
questions today or our first voicemail
is from Betsy in Muncie Indiana I just
had a question about how you guys kind
of deal with some negative emotions I
work as an advocate for domestic
violence and sexual assault victims it's
something that I'm really passionate
about and something that I you know I'm
really happy to spend a lot of my time
doing and cultivating that that passion
and working in that field but I also
find that it brings a lot of negative
emotions and things that can kind of
cloud up my emotion for other things in
my life and I find that it kind of
creeps into all areas and affects my
mood at a lot of time so I wondered how
do you guys deal with that and kind of
compartmentalizing those emotions or
maybe just learning how to you know live
in a simple way where you can kind of
separate those things out from other
areas of your life so those those
emotions you're feeling are definitely a
type of noise and so when I think about
well first off Betsy let me say thank
you for what you do I mean you're doing
some really important work you're
contributing to your community there but
contributing to the world around you and
I just want to say thank you I really
appreciate that
amen and I know the the people that
you're helping certainly appreciate it
as well even if they're not always able
to communicate that and they may not
realize that you're experiencing these
these emotions because often we don't
wear our heart on our sleeve and often
it's not good to do that but also you
mentioned well how do i compartmentalize
these emotions and I'll tell you
throughout my 20s I was a mozart of
compartmentalization I I never wore my
heart on my sleeves and I would try to
constantly just sort of well I'm gonna
box up this emotion and put it over here
and this the
over there that's the wrong thing for us
to do because what we're doing it's it's
it's like the metaphor
you know sweeping the dirt under the rug
the dirt is still there you've just
moved it somewhere else you've
compartmentalised the dirt and I think
we can do that with our emotions and
then of course there are unfortunate
consequences that that peak their head
around the corner and it's not right
away so you don't you don't experience
the negative effects right away maybe a
year later a decade later or several
decades later where all of a sudden you
have this realization that wow I hid
that emotion instead of trying to deal
with it and so what I would say is
recognize the the emotion for what it is
and also recognize the positive emotions
that you get from this more importantly
you know your life is basically what you
focus on and so while we can recognize
the negative emotion that you're feeling
if it's sadness or if it's anger or if
it's distress realize that many of those
emotions even if they're negative
emotions they can be beneficial because
they they allow us to make a change what
we don't want to do however is wallow in
the the sorrow and so you want to notice
those peak emotions as well is I say
peak intentionally here it's like if you
see a mountain you can't have the
mountain without the valley and so these
these negative emotions of the valley
that the key is not to wallow in in
those emotions I know Ryan and I you we
just did this podcast episode about
about the election and I heard from a
lot of people who have been wallowing
they have been upset with with the
outcome for you know whatever reason
because maybe they really liked Hilary
or maybe they just really dislike Donald
Trump sort of and they've wallowed and
in this sorrow and I don't think the
suffering is productive I think it's
okay to to feel pain but but then do
something about that pain for you you
you want to focus on something figure
out what that the meaning of the thing
is what's the meaning of this emotion
and then take action on that and then
more importantly let's find out what
emotions you're experiencing that are
happy that we produce more of those so
we have more Peaks on on the the overall
landscape and realize that many of these
emotions you have control over you can't
change the things you don't have control
over but you do have control over your
your emotions and it's just like a
muscle you can train yourself to to over
time experience fewer negative emotions
or experience those negative emotions
for a shorter duration and if you're
doing if you're doing that if you're not
wallowing if you're staying in that
valley for a short period of time but
then ascending the mountain that for
that you can experience more of the
positive without suffering through a lot
of of the negative yeah a Betsy when I
was listening to your comment you know I
just thought to myself wow like here is
a gal who is taking the world on her
shoulders well I mean it Nina
maybe not the entire world but the
people that you interact with you are
taking taking a lot of their world on
and putting it on your shoulders and the
first thing I ask myself is well who's
taking it on for Betsy so I think that's
the only thing I would add here is find
find someone that you can you know kind
of dump these experiences on whether
it's a friend or family member or even
if it's a therapist I mean there's
nothing wrong with with seeing someone
on a weekly bi-weekly basis to just kind
of unload all your emotions on I used to
do that in the corporate world and it
was really really helpful it's not like
a like a catch-all I think this is just
one ingredient to to getting that noise
to set to silence that noise but I think
it's a great step to help you do that
Betsy Betsy thank you for your question
I'd love to give you a copy of our book
essential it's an essay collection Ryan
and I wrote 150 essays about 12
different topics everything from
minimalism and stuff to success but also
we have a chapter in there about
mindfulness and I think that chapter
will help you quiet some of the the
noise and deal with some of the negative
emotions that you have so you can
experience more joy and more
satisfaction
and the work that you're doing so thank
you for what you do and thank you for
your question our next question is from
Jessica in North Carolina I think for as
long as I can remember
I've been using I guess you would say
white noise to help me get to sleep
usually this takes the form of something
that reminds me of conversations had in
another room just kind of lulls me to
sleep recently but for the past year
it's taken on the form of listening to
old sci-fi TV episodes things that I've
seen hundreds of times so I'm not
interested in actually staying up and
seeing what happens but I play it on my
on a video app on my phone listen to it
on my earphones turn it down to barely
audible or flip the phone upside down so
I don't actually see it my husband sort
of half joking half serious it says that
I have a problem and that I should be
maybe listening to something that I
would learn something maybe suggesting
y'all's podcast but for me that's kind
of the opposite of what I'm trying to do
because if I listened to your podcast
but I'm interested in what you have to
say and I don't go to sleep so I guess
the point is could you help us sort of
settle our debate do I need minimalist
therapy for my white noise addiction or
am I getting value-added from my audio
only
HiFi sleep assistance Jessica you know I
don't know what should she do here I
mean I don't know what you should do
what I'll say is this if I was sleeping
trying to sleep listening to old sci-fi
shows I would not get very good sleep I
know whenever I have like whenever I've
tried to sleep with a TV on in the
background it's like the the the shows
kind of dictate my dreams and I really
don't get like a fully restful sleep but
Jessica that doesn't mean that this
isn't a good tactic for you I mean
if it works great that would not work
for me personally I'll tell you what I
personally do is I will I do have like a
fan that will provide some white noise
which really helps and then also Mariah
and I we have a sleep meditation that we
will will use I shall put that in the
show notes for anyone out there who's
interested in it it's kind of a it's
kind of a it's kind of cheesy but it
works it's like this very like soothing
you know music and like kind of like
this think of the most like cliche
you know meditation guided meditation
they could think of like it it's very
much like that but but that's just kind
of the point though it's it's banal yeah
and and it's something that is a lot
easier to fall asleep - so Jessica yeah
you know I don't I don't have anything
I'm going to tell you that you should or
shouldn't do I do it's funny you
mentioned that the the sleep meditation
I've tried that with with Bex and I mean
she she is so she has totally changed
the way she sleeps but she when I first
met her and we first started dating she
was literally the worst person I've ever
seen in terms of like falling asleep and
insomnia and and so I do it's I it's so
easy for me to fall asleep at night
it's not always easy for me to stay
asleep but I I will fall asleep
instantly at night and so doing this a
meditation at night like we would be 30
seconds in and I'm snoring get upset so
you get you got to make sure that's not
it Jessica first thing I'll you asked
about your your husband and you said is
he right or am i right what your
husband's wrong and of course you don't
want to tell him that so maybe you if
you want to play this back to him I'll
tell him he's wrong yeah that's okay and
the reason he's wrong is because what
you're doing isn't working for you right
and I agree with Ryan if what you were
doing worked and you were getting great
sleep but clearly it's not working
because you're calling in and you're
you're asking about this and you said
you need some white noise to fall asleep
I think that's fine in fact I'll
recommend some things that will help you
go to sleep but if
you things you don't want to do you
don't want to turn your brain on at
night so listening to engaging podcasts
you know if our podcast puts you to
sleep then you know then we have a
different problem but it sounds like
what you're saying is our podcast
wouldn't put you to sleep and you don't
want to engage the what we call the
monkey mind right you with a monkey
brain you don't you don't want that you
want something that's gonna put you in a
state that allows you to be more
creative more imaginative so first thing
I recommend is yes if you want to do
something before bed maybe read some
fiction and we have a list of many of my
favorite novels and short story
collections over at the minimalists comm
slash recommendation there's a bunch of
book recommendations there we can put
that in the show notes for you as well
but you want to do something that's
going to turn your mind off so it could
be the meditation it could be reading a
fiction there's a bunch of things that
that you don't want to do
oh and speaking of a reading by the way
let me go back for a second you may want
to get your your husband to read it to
you I know that I do that often at night
with with Becca well I'll read a short
story to her or you know read something
that I've been generalized something
that's fiction and I'll read that to her
and I know that that definitely helps
out if if we're reading at night but
here here are some things that you want
to do you talked about white noise well
the the best thing that I found for
white noise something called a dome
sound conditioner that's do H M but
we'll put a link to the one that I use
in the show nose I got this Rebecca and
it plugs into the wall but it's not
making noise like a lot of speaker it's
a series of fans and the National Sleep
Association they it's the official sort
of noise conditioner or sound
conditioner of the National Sleep
Association and man it creates just this
great white noise that is not
overpowering but especially when we were
living over by where the trains are I
mean that helped out a lot but even now
like it's it's far less it's far less
noisy outside but any little thing will
wake up Becca and so the the sound
conditioner helps out with that here a
bunch of other things that have helped
Beck's over the
the the last year or two she has a sleep
mask I have a sleep mask as well I use a
really nice one that is like it wraps
around your ears and it's really soft
I'll put a link to the one that I use
and the show knows I also use some ear
plugs called ear piece like PE AC e
piece ear piece blackout curtains are
important as so you don't get any light
in in fact you want to reduce all of the
the light especially the blue light that
you're experiencing in the evenings to
reset your circadian rhythm and to do
that you want to have no screen time
after it gets dark because what happens
is this the blue the blue light in your
TV or your phone or wherever it triggers
your brain to make you think it's still
light outside it's still sunny out
because it still sunny out you want to
be awake and so it makes it harder to go
to sleep and harder to stay asleep as
well so you can install something on
your computer it's free it's called flux
it's a screen but basically it puts a
filter on your screen that removes all
the blue light so you can do that on
your computer it's just F dot lu x is
the website we'll put a link to that in
the show notes as well and we've talked
about this before but let's talk about
it again
the calm stuff ryan i know you've been
using that and it seems like that's been
been working for you pretty well it's
like magnesium
yeah there's it's like every little
thing that you just mentioned it adds
like a significant i'm sorry a little
bit a little significant increase to
like my sleep so so like the calm helps
a little bit the eye mask helps a little
bit right the ear plugs helped a little
bit yes
all these incremental change yeah
melatonin helps a little bit so like all
that stuff added up yeah it works really
really really well think about that if
you're making I couldn't I can't sleep
until I cannot sleep until noon like I
used to when I was in high school not
that I want to sleep in but yeah but
like I can get a solid like seven or
eight hours now with very little tossing
and turning compared to if I didn't use
any of that stuff yeah I try to make
sure I get eight to nine hours every
night especially since I've been trying
to
my body and my back a few other things
that helped me so you've got the the
column we just talked about it's just a
powder he put into warm water at night
it's magnesium if you want to do
melatonin I I would encourage you to
cycle on and off of that I know Shawn
you've been doing that recently and that
that has helped podcast Shawn our
producer here he has been doing some
melatonin supplementation and and you
can do that start off really small what
is it like like three milligrams or
something yeah so so start off small you
can do a little spray under your tongue
or the little the pills will work as
well but you don't want to become
dependent on that either so it's good to
cycle on cycle off with that also
something the Beck's uses is something
called new mood which has l-tryptophan
and some other stuff in it that helps
with serotonin production and which
helps which helps her sleep as well a
few other things that I do stretching
rug before I go to bed because I have
back pain so anyone who has any pain at
night the stretching really helps also
putting a pillow between my legs at
night helps me stay asleep because of my
back pain and I will do a sauna often
and I think I'm going to sauna tonight
to you know just just feel better and
and and and detox and it also helps out
with my hormones and my mood regulation
and everything but the sauna at night
helps me stay asleep longer and and feel
you know feel more calm also put your
devices in airplane mode or I would just
say get your phone out of the bedroom
altogether certainly don't have a TV in
your bedroom
Bennett is meant for two things neither
of which are watching reruns and and so
it's crazy how like the articles that
have come out about how the Wi-Fi signal
is and how so even if you have a modem
that's like in your room for internet
like unplug that yeah so yeah the the
Wi-Fi signal from your phone the
cellular cellular signal from your phone
like there's studies that show how much
that interrupts people sleep patterns
yeah the EMFs so it has a lot of
potential downside so anything that's
Bluetooth or Wi-Fi yeah we have a light
switch it turns off our Wi-Fi
at night and so you can you can do any
of these things and like Raya said its
incremental so you make a 10% change
tinder I should say 10 degree change
right so the thing about that is if you
make 10 10 degree changes you've made a
hundred degree shift in your sleep
pattern and so all of these little
things they they add up and and they
count let's talk about like what not to
do like don't drink alcohol
oh where you go to bed that's one of the
worst things to do it's fine cos like
when I was younger I used to think like
oh just like I'll just have like a
little glass of whiskey or have a couple
beers and it does it helps you get to
sleep but the problem is like you don't
really stay asleep in the sleep you do
get is not good sleep the other thing
too is don't eat before bed yes like
eating what is it within like 3 hours 2
hours yeah longer if you can't yeah if
you can go for 5 hours because what's
happening is your body has to then
expend energy to instead of recovering
and that's what sleep is for is
recovering at night it's it's in trying
to digest all of all the food that that
you ate you know an hour before you went
to bed and so it makes it more difficult
for your body to to experience rest for
sure what else what else shouldn't we do
don't watch TV what else yeah I mean
avoid avoid any lights oh so dim the
lights and at night and and try to have
as few lights possible in fact we use a
few amber lights so without any blue
light in it so that we have we we can
still see at night because in Montana
gets dark at 4:30 p.m. and in the winter
and and so having some amber light which
still allows you to illuminate your
house and then going back to to reading
I think reading will really help you in
fact Jessica let me usually don't send
this to anyone but let me send you a
copy I wrote a novel in my 20s it's
called as a decade fades and we'll give
you the either the print or eBook
version on on that and maybe maybe my
book will help you get to sleep some of
the best writing I ever did in my 20s
and and and it's completely different
from any of the the minimalist stuff
that we've done but it's a book I was I
was really proud of and
and so hopefully that that created that
I'll get your your creative mind working
and help you get into that Ryan right
before we start recording we talked
about the the alpha brainwaves versus
the beta brainwaves so when you sleep
you experience these alpha brainwaves
and and when you wake up in the morning
you're still you're in flux between
alpha brainwaves and beta brainwaves and
so at night what you're trying to do is
transition back in and I think reading
some sort of a fiction or stories will
will help you in that process transition
from wakefulness to restful sleep our
next question is from Lindsay in Indiana
when you have a mental illness I have
ADHD and I have a mind that moves faster
than anything you can imagine I very
much want to slow down my brain and the
things I own so that those don't fog up
my mind I'm so wrapped up in the moment
and don't think about the world that is
going around around me I am also in
management and can't seem to tame or
figure out how to tackle the paper beast
that my that it takes for me to kind of
stay on track are there any tips that
you can give to help the mental mind
clutter or the paper clutter and all the
stuff in general that ensues with ADHD I
think the first thing we want to do is
reframe what what we're talking about
you know I think xx Robbins would say
decisions not conditions determine our
destiny and what you're saying right now
is I have a condition and it's a
limiting belief basically and so we want
to change that belief yes you may have
ADHD and I'm sure Ryan will be able to
talk about that and it's easy for me to
say I have OCD and that's a limiting
belief and in my own life whenever
whenever I think about these these
conditions that determine my life I
realize I need to make different
decisions about what I focus on what I
find meaning in and so I can take
actions accordingly and you can realize
that that the language that we use
instead of instead of calling
your condition ADHD instead of calling
it a you know a mental illness let's
acknowledge that you learn differently
as a person and that can be beneficial
to you yes your brain may work more
quickly than other people but that in
many in many instances that is a benefit
not a bug and and so that's a feature of
someone who can engage more quickly who
can problem-solve more quickly and in
fact you can look at a lot of people
that who have suppose an ADHD and
realize that there's some of the most
productive and successful people look at
Silicon Valley I mean everyone there has
ADHD and and they're they're wildly
successful in many senses they're
they're making an impact on the world
that many of us can only dream of
because they've taken that condition
that they have and decided that you know
what this is this is a a benefit for me
in terms of slowing down I mean you can
look at the you know the research
there's been a lot of research talks
about K through 12 meditation has helped
a lot of kids with ADHD so if you
haven't tried meditation yet you you'll
want to get a start with a a meditation
app like headspace or 10% happier or Sam
Harris has a couple of free guided
meditation the nine-minute one a 27
minute one we have links of those on our
website the minimalists com Sam we did
an interview with him on that and also
in terms of more research they found out
especially for kids that exercise is
really important for kids with ADHD so
I'm assuming adults with ADHD it's going
to it's going to be the same thing so
you may want to consider yoga IIIi think
that that does that kills two birds with
one stone here because you get the
physical aspect then you can be rigorous
especially something like hot yoga it
can be really rigorous but it also gives
you that that mental calmness as well so
so it turns down the noise physically
and mentally at the same time a few
other things that I might recommend
we already talked about asana by what in
fact i'll do mindfulness meditation in
the sun as long as no one else there I
go to the YMCA for the sauna so
sometimes there are other people there
but if there isn't I will do mindfulness
meditation in the the sauna Ryan this
this past weekend I had to go out I was
actually on Monday I had to go to
Spokane to get some blood work done and
so Bex and I went out there we just made
the Spokane's like the the closest city
to where we live I mean it's I don't
it's it's a city right but we live in a
city I suppose but like if you want
access to to everyday city kind of
things you you tend to go to Spokane or
even Seattle but we went out to smoke in
and decide to make a sort of a day trip
out of it and I did several things that
really helped calm my mind so I went
floating I'm really looking forward to
doing a float tank once they once they
come here because it's just like a sauna
you get benefit from at one time but you
get far more benefit from doing a a
float tank if you can do it two three
four times a week I love floating like
well out of the hour there's like 15
minutes that I love yeah yeah but
because because why though because you
start to relax yeah yeah but at first it
like turns up the volume you realize
like oh my god there's so much noise in
my head and also noise in my body -
right because flow tanks are are for
those of you who aren't acquainted with
it a flow tank is a sensory deprivation
right and so you're you're floating in
93 or 94 degree water that is the same
temperatures your skin is pitch pitch
black so you can't see anything you
can't feel anything there's no noise so
you can't hear anything and so you feel
like oh I didn't realize my knee was
aching today I didn't oh and my back was
hurting more than I realized and what is
all these thoughts in my head and
they're zooming zooming zooming zooming
you feel for a person who doesn't have
ADHD you feel like all of a sudden you
do because you've turned everything else
down and the only the only sensation is
what's going on inside your your body
and so float tanks they turn everything
up so that you can turn everything down
so I I definitely recommend that I also
did cryo
Arpi while I was out there is that
there's finally a cryo place and in
Spokane which is pretty awesome the guy
who runs it pat at Spokane cryo and he's
a really really great guy just like
really funny and it's in the middle of
this weird little Plaza thing it's like
in the back of a building somewhere and
you just go in but it was great and for
me I was talking to BEC about this
because for her it many people they do
cryotherapy and it's like it's
terrifying or it's really cold is- 230
degrees fahrenheit for 3 minutes for me
it's a meditative experience I don't
know if you experienced that whenever
you've done cryo but but it because
you're the first time it's shocking I
mean it really is yeah the first time
it's like I mean that's why they allow
you to go only like a minute or two they
don't they won't even let you do the
full time yeah because of how shocking
it is the first time but yeah like once
you get used to and you realize like
okay you're but it's like mentally you
know you're not gonna die like
intellectually you can understand this
but as soon as that cold hits your body
like your body doesn't understand that
right so there is this like initial wave
of like panic but like once you your
body gets used to it and like realizes
like okay I'm not gonna die then yeah it
is certainly a meditative experience but
yeah that first time is uh not so
meditative I would say I agree with that
you you it's it's psychological but once
you get back once you know that like
okay this is gonna be fine and yes it's
going to be cold negative 230 degrees is
really freaking cold although I'll tell
you it's not as miserable as taking an
ice bath no not at all and on last
episode the gift-giving episode I talked
about speaking of gift-giving these are
all things we're talking right now these
are great gifts you can give someone
float tank like sensory deprivation sure
is some of the great crowd therapy if
you have it nearby is is an interesting
gift that you can experience with
someone else but I found that the first
time I did did cry Oh like yeah it was
really cold but it was still better than
than doing an ice bath dude an ice bath
sucks every single time well almost
every time so when I go to the the
Russian bathhouse vote a spa and in Los
Angeles it they have what is colder than
an ice bath it's 30 degrees Wednesday
yeah yeah it's salinated plunge pool you
go from 200
agree you're sweating your butt off and
then you go from that to 230 degrees and
it is euphoric how long do you stay in
the plunge pool I I will often stay a
minute but man once you get past a
minute like once you get past 10 seconds
it's like oh my goodness like this is
really really terrifyingly cold but well
and then when you get out you spend five
minutes just sitting down it is euphoria
I mean it is it's really amazing because
and also it really helps it boost your
immune system which which is a nice
benefit for me I do it for pain
management so my back's really bad so I
do cryotherapy it radically reduces
inflammation radically reduces the pain
that I have and a lot of athletes do it
for quick recovery same reason they
would do an ice bath or anything like
that but these are different ways to
basically what all we're saying here
Ryan is find ways to change your state
you're in a pattern right now you change
your state to break that pattern and
that will help you reorganize
reconstitute your thoughts and
ultimately turn down the noise yeah
Lindsay you know you're she posited her
question you know how can you be a
minimalist or is it possible to be
minimalist that's what it was is it
possible to be a minimalist when you
have a mental illness and you know I
just want to you know reiterate what
minimalism is it's about using your
resources consciously using them
deliberately and the resources the
resource I should say that you're asking
about specifically is your attention and
I can tell you that being ADHD myself
it's very important for me to be
deliberate with my attention so I'll
tell you first and foremost the most
important thing for me is having a
having something to do like having my
day planned out because I'll tell you my
ADHD really really flares up when I have
nothing to do it's like if I'm sitting
there and I don't have something to do
for a couple hours then I want to do a
million different things and what ends
up happening is I kind of get frozen
with you know too many choices and then
I'll just
and veg I'll get on Facebook or get on
YouTube or whatever so I'll say you know
if you don't have a schedule in your
life right now get a schedule that is
something that really really helps me
like I'll tell you my what what a
typical day for me what it looks like
now this is a typical day this isn't
every single day I'm not perfect with it
but most days I will wake around like
7:00 7:30 a.m. I will make some coffee
make some tea from Riya and then we are
off to the gym and then after the gym
I'll come home shower get ready and then
by 10:30 ish I will either be reading or
I will be writing or sometimes I will
catch up on email just depending on what
what my day is is like and then from
there basically between 12:00 and 6:00
p.m. I am either mentoring I am reading
I'm writing or I am again doing like
social media that's usually when I check
social media is usually around 5:00 p.m.
so those those are things that it's not
a like this super strict schedule but
what I have are very very limited
options to choose from so I usually do
about two to three mentoring
appointments a day so that takes up the
majority of that afternoon time but if I
have an open afternoon then guess what I
can be reading writing or again like
checking up on on email so I would say
limit your options and use the schedule
by far like going over the schedule the
day before helps me helped me to plan
that out a lot better as well
and I think this can carry over to your
just this approach of having you know a
tool to help you I think this can carry
over to your paper issue that you talked
about having at work get a system down
with your paper like right now I'm just
like imagining her having like these
six-foot stacks of paper on her desk
where she can like barely even fit like
a laptop on there or something if that's
the case then yeah it's gonna take a lot
of work to get those stacks of paper
organized but
you get a system down whether it's
scanning them whether it's archiving
them and putting them in boxes and I
mean I remember at our old at our old
jobs Josh we had at a retail stores we
had all that customer paperwork we had
to hold onto contracts is like response
boxes right and what we would do is we
would literally put him in a box ok this
is December and then we would you know
call whatever company wants to come and
pick it up and they would archive that
work we had a system yeah we had a
system in place so yes the initial work
is going to be it's gonna be hard but
once you get that out of the way and
start implementing your system Lindsey
whether it's with the schedule or
whether it's with you know your papers I
promise you it will help it will help
during those times when you're feeling
like your ADHD is flaring up if you've
got a system in place it definitely
helps quiet the mind to things you
reminded me of that Ryan one is Greg
McEwan wrote a book called essentialism
and in there he in the book he talks
about designing your week and so he said
you know a month is too far out because
it it's like trying to plan your year
like yes you can you can take broad
strokes but you don't have planned
entire month in advance and you don't
want to plan just a day in advance
because then you get caught up in the
inputs of everyone else and I think
that's important to think about with
with a lot of of what we're doing a lot
of this noise it means we're just
responding to us or Ryan just said like
if you if you have an hour to kill
basically and what often do we do your
average person checks email 150 times a
day now or 150 times a day estudio us
yeah yeah absolutely well in fact we
were on the hot the high end of things
so the the supposed high performers
check their email as often as 900 times
a day Wow but let's think of let's do
the math on that that's once a minute
every minute for 16 hours straight yeah
that's crazy so so we what happens
that's that is noise but it's us
allowing other people to dictate our day
yeah and so if you're really struggling
with with all of this noise quite often
it's because other people are dictating
your day and you don't even realize it
might be people in your social media
feed it could be your email it can be
the news because the news is what it's
shocking its titillating it's always
trying to get us to click here click
here you you don't if you see a news
story from BuzzFeed or whatever and it
says today is a good day you're probably
not gonna click on it but if you if you
see the thing that says terrorist threat
is looming in Missoula Montana you're
gonna click on it because all of a
sudden you you it's supposed to jolt you
that's what they're trying to do they're
dictating not only your day but they're
dictating your emotions and I think it's
important to remove ourselves from that
back to the and I think the way to
remove ourself from that is to plan out
your week in advance having a a weekly
design session as a Greg McEwen calls it
to design your week around what your
priorities are and don't let other
people dictate your priorities and also
in that book he talks about the term
priority yeah up until the 20th century
the word literally means the thing
before priority mmm the thing prior and
and think about that for a second the
first thing is what it means and not
into the 20th century
did we say well that's more than one
thing it's no longer our priority it's a
whole set of priorities now Ryan I did a
whole episode on priorities you can go
back and check that out in our in our
podcast feed but we want to have as few
priorities as possible in order to do
that we can design what our week looks
like scheduled downtime scheduled time
for yourself because sometimes the
things that don't seem productive alone
time or or restful time those things are
productive because the word prod what's
the product well I am feeling more
restful that is a product of having rest
time and that allows you to be to better
perform in other areas of your life so
schedule in that rest schedule in the
alone time schedule in time with friends
schedule a time for your health and you
can do that early on in the week so that
you you feel good
about the productivity of your week yeah
the biggest I think the biggest takeaway
here cuz like going over my schedule for
example it works for me
but it could be a little confusing for
some but I think the biggest takeaway
here is to be proactive like I mean if
that's the one and piece of advice I
guess Lindsey I could really give you
that helps me with my ADHD is being
proactive as much as possible and back
to the paperwork the mountains of
paperwork if it is too much for you to
deal with there's a company called one
dollar scan comm they are not a sponsor
I've not used them personally but I've
had a lot of our readers comment about
them and so if you're not wanting to do
a scanning party you can see what
scanner I use for all the paperwork the
Ryan and I have you we've done a
scanning party of our own we wrote about
that at the minimalists comm slash
scanning and you could find the exact
paper scanner that I use you can feed
papers into it really quickly with that
scanner but if you don't want to do that
you can send off boxes of your own
paperwork and old books and everything
else to one dollar scan comm it's the
number one dollar scan comm last thing
I'll tell you Lindsey is anxiety this
anxiety that you're feeling it was often
tied to our memories what does that mean
it means we're spending a lot of time in
the past and we're not going to get
where we're going we're not going to get
to the destination if we're constantly
living in the rearview mirror so instead
let's keep our eyes on the road keep our
eyes and the journey ahead of us let's
try to live in the moment
let's live right now and occasionally
glance toward the horizon of what's
going on in the future
one question to ask yourself is is this
useful so if you're experienced in an
emotion if you're experiencing a thought
if you feel that there is a too much
paper clutter in your life
ask yourself those three the three words
is this useful and our friend Dan Harris
talks about this in our documentary so
Lindsey there's a whole mindfulness
section in our documentary called
minimalism will either send you the
online version it's on iTunes and Amazon
and
Google Play and Vimeo and all those
places you can find that at minimalism
film comm but we'll send you a copy of
that or we'll send you the the DVD it
just came out on on DVD as well so
either way Lindsay we hope you find some
value and that our next question is from
Nora in Ithaca New York I just wanted to
ask if you guys could talk about how
being a minimalist how that can be
possible when you're literally in this
bubble of people that aren't minimalist
and also you know I know that you guys
came from corporate jobs and I think
that's really really impressive but I
also was very much consumer driven I
spent hundreds of dollars on skin care
products beauty products clothing things
that I really didn't need and you know
that transition can be I think a lot
more difficult than if you were you know
already pretty simple and now you just
wanted to take that extra step so
basically two issues I would like you to
address the first is how to be a
minimalist when everyone around you is
just wealthier and you know when it
comes to it down to you know people's
items are there social to find their
social status and when you're in college
when you're in a in this bubble it's not
as easy as you know when you're living
alone or when you have opportunity to
change and then the second one is you
know how do you do that when you were so
so hardcore consumer-driven Nora if my
advice would be get out of your bubble
like that's that's step number one
I mean we talked about that during our
podcast called blame where we were
talking about the election and how
important it is to to seek out
differences of opinions so there's a
there's a couple ways you can get out of
your bubble you could go I don't know
how close it is to Buffalo or Rochester
are those are not too far yeah well I
mean there's a basically go to
minimalist org and you can click on
Buffalo or rochester whichever is closer
and you can plan to meet
with with that minimalist group they
meet once a month so it's something you
could plan well in advance for or if you
don't have time to drive an hour to
however long it takes to get to one of
those places you can certainly go to
meetup.com and search for different
groups in your area and here's what I
would say to Nora is yes go seek out
people who are like-minded open-minded
who do want to live a simple life who
wants to incorporate minimalism into
their life but I'd also encourage you to
go hang out with people who you could
see yourself never hanging out with
let's say it's um you know a ador group
and you can never see yourself acting or
even being interested in theatre well
just go hang out with those guys get a
different perspective get a different
get a different opinion on things and
yeah no matter what that's that's uh
that's a important thing I think for for
life in general is to not put yourself
in a bubble of just people who agree
with you 100% of the time to answer your
second question about how to be a
minimalist when you're so you're such a
yeah you're such a consumer you're
you're so what did she say
consumer-driven so hard consumer-driven
I think is what she said you know you've
discovered some unmeaning phille habits
that you have in your life and you want
to change that so you know the first
question I would ask is what are some
meaningful habits you'd like to
incorporate with your new approach to
life and just pick one of those to start
with just one so if it's well you want
to contribute more you go to the soup
kitchen go to you know Habitat for
Humanity go out and do those things and
the more that you incorporate good
habits into your life there won't be as
much room for the bad habits so yeah
just start with one thing and and
keep kind of piling on from there once
you feel like you can add add another
thing I agree with with going slowly
there and and but it's about starting
now right a change changing the focus
now slowly surrounding yourself with new
people so Ryan mentioned minimalist
dot-org that we have free local meetup
groups in a hundred cities in eight
different countries you can just go to
minimalist org and find a meetup group
that is close to you and if you can't
find one close to you we do an online
meetup once a month over at minimalist
or we have an online city and we just
call it the online city and so you can
connect with thousands of other people
who will help support you and that's
really what you want to do you're
surrounding yourself with people who
have similar values they're not always
like-minded but they tend to be
open-minded and so identify what your
values are and surround yourself with
people who have similar values Ryan and
I tend to have different beliefs but we
have have the same values we even have
different interests and and that's okay
but but if you put yourself in a group a
new bubble or expand your bubble to
people with the similar values as you
and by the way you're at the best time
to do this you're in college where
people tend to be a lot more open-minded
to to change you get a group of people
who are in their 80s or 90s they're less
likely to make a change is it possible
sure it is we've had people in their
90's show up at events and say I'm just
becoming a minimalist for the first time
in my life
it's less likely though you're at a time
of exploration right now take advantage
of of that exploration you don't have to
necessarily leap up and call yourself a
minimalist it's one of the most
difficult things you can do actually
because other people think you're gonna
kill yourself or whatever all you're
getting rid of your stuff well no you
can just start simplifying your life and
then show other people the benefits of
what you're experiencing you don't have
to say look at me I'm becoming a
minimalist and I need you to share my
values no you can go find other people
who have similar of values one of my
favorite lines from our book everything
that remains is you can't change the
people around you but you can change the
people around you and what I mean by
that is you can't try to change someone
even if you know you love them you care
about them you can't change
that person but you can change the group
of people you associate with and start
associating with people the the who you
aspire to be like and I think it's
important to surround yourself with
people is surround yourself with people
who are similar to the person you want
to become that's gonna help you grow
it's also gonna be uncomfortable you're
gonna feel a lot of discomfort at first
you're gonna put yourself in and what I
like to call the discomfort zone but
that's the place from which you grow the
most and the more you grow the more you
have to give the more you give the more
you grow and it's a really beautiful
cycle also last thing I'll say is
there's nothing necessarily inherently
wrong with consumption we all need some
stuff right
the problem is compulsory consumption or
compulsive consumption and so don't
think of yourself as they can sumer
think of yourself as a citizen who often
needs to buy things to to live and
that's okay but the things that we
surround ourselves with we shouldn't try
to find meaning in those things those
things should simply augment our our
experience of life and if we consume
less that opens up more time for
creativity and the more we create
generally there are a lot of studies
that show the more we create the happier
that we that we feel and so if you're
consuming less creating more you're
probably gonna feel a lot happier
you mentioned Ryan's and my journey from
the corporate world so we both grew up
really poor and then climb the corporate
ladder made a lot of money doing that
throughout our 20s and Trent and then
eventually realize that wasn't making us
happy and we had to transition into a
life that wasn't consumer driven it was
a life a simpler life a life of more
meaning Ryan and I wrote about that
journey the last those five years of our
lives from suit-and-tie corporate guys
and also our childhoods and and the
drugs and alcohol all that stuff was
going on a childhood level growing up
poor and then our journey from the
suit-and-tie corporate guys to becoming
minimalists and then the minimalist we
wrote about that and a book called
everything that remains and Nora I'd
love to send you a copy of that the
first seven chapters really cover that
transition in detail from these these
suit-and-tie corporate guys to changing
our habits not just getting rid of bad
habits but replacing them
with with better ones our next question
is from Victoria in Findlay Ohio my
question today is about criticism I
heard you guys were reaching out if we
had any comments and I'm an INTJ -
briggs personality test and so for me
criticism something I love and I thrive
on and I look for that and I want people
to give me criticism constructing
criticism output that way because that
is how I can be self-aware and
self-developed in that area so for me I
really look for that however I struggle
with people being honest and like giving
me that giving that to me
and then I assume that other people want
that as well so I feel like I have a big
just like separation from people and how
I'm being you know translating
everything and so I had to come by
myself that not everybody likes
criticism and people don't want to
necessarily hear the things that I have
to say but I do want to hear the things
that they don't want to say yeah
Victoria I think Josh would agree with
this that yeah we definitely appreciate
you know helpful criticism and you know
I think like you know you have a good
friend when they could come up to you
and be like hey your breath stinks put a
mint in your mouth like I really
appreciate it when when someone does
that for me like Mariah come up to and
be like hey you might want to chew some
gum someone offers me gone that's I
always accept decision I assume my
breath is awful I've you know I'm in the
constant state of perpetual fear of
halitosis for some reason yeah I know
I'm with you man but you know even from
readers like I appreciate hearing the
different points of use to help me make
sure that I'm considering all sides
because that's something that I really
kind of pride myself on is you know
being able to kind of look at a
situation through different lenses and
being able to make a good decision based
on those different opinions so yeah I
certainly welcome that now I agree with
you - you don't want to give criticism
to someone who didn't ask for it and
certainly if you don't know the person
they're not your friend they're not in
that in that primary circle you wouldn't
want to go up to and be like hey your
breath stinks have a mint you would want
to approach that situation much much
differently but what I will say Victoria
the one thing that helps me whenever I'm
giving any any criticism to anyone is
when I am I avoid using the word you so
I will never say you know maybe to Josh
I will say hey your breath stinks I'm
like in that situation but let's let's
take that example if I'm gonna go to
someone who is that I just that I first
met and they are their breath stinks so
I would approach that in the way of like
hey you know I know that if my breath
stunk I would really want someone to
tell me is that something that you would
want someone to do for you right and you
can kind of position it that way like
again like when you use the word you you
use an ambivalent or in a complimentary
way never in a negative way
always use I if you're saying something
negative it's a very good way to help
people not feel so defensive
take honor show yeah and it doesn't put
blame on the other person you you you if
you can kind of put it on yourself
it makes the the criticism a lot easier
to digest I think we need to be honest
too about this Ryan with Victoria is she
says she likes criticism she wants
criticism no you don't you don't want
criticism what you what you want is the
outcome the critic criticism provides
you so we need to take a step beyond
criticism you don't like criticism
because criticism is not necessarily
good or bad most criticism is is
nonsense is vapid it's trite it's it
doesn't make any sense it's trolls on
the Internet
especially as you put yourself out there
more and more and more and you're going
to get criticized more so Victoria what
you want isn't criticism you said you
want to be more self-aware you want to
develop you want to grow as the word I
would use
and and the criticism helps you do that
so really if you want to give criticism
to other people it's not because you I
mean it would be
kind of rude to just want to criticize
other people that makes you a critic and
and I have very little use for critics I
have a lot of use for friends who want
to add value to my life in fact the fact
I surround myself with with people who I
trust and their opinion even when it's
different from mine I'll reach out for
that kind of feedback so instead of
maybe providing criticism to the people
around you what if you're out to provide
feedback and in position it in a way
frame it in a way that help them become
more self-aware more developed help them
grow as an individual
wouldn't that be a lot better than
simply criticizing them because if
you're just criticizing for the sake of
criticizing well then you are a seagull
and and we have an essay on our website
about this called seagulls I'm gonna
read a quick excerpt from that criticism
is inevitable unless you do nothing
important with your life but whenever
you put yourself out there
whenever you expose your ideas to the
world be it via social media blogs or
business meetings you're effectively
wearing a sign that says criticize me of
course some criticism is beneficial
feedback from people we respect helps us
grow other criticism however is toxic
the most virulent example is the cynical
internet troll trolls are like seagulls
they fly in crap all over you and they
fly away they're too stupid to
understand the implications of their own
actions truth be told most critics bring
nothing to the table they simply project
their own insecurities and add zero
value to the conversation and if we
listen to them their toxicity permeates
our thoughts making it difficult to
create anything worthwhile so you have
two choices either create and be
criticized or hide from meaningful work
because you're scared of a little bird
poop personally I'd rather cover my head
and craft something worth criticizing I
just think that's something worth we're
thinking about here is if we're going to
be creating then yes we do want that
feed
that is helpful but from whom not from
everyone there's 7 billion people in the
world you don't want feedback from
everyone you want from people that you
trust you value their opinion surround
yourself with people who can give you
that feedback that you need and when
you're we you are that role when you're
fulfilling that role for someone else
provide the feedback in a way that is
not a critique but it is it is truly
feedback in a way that they can use or
don't have to use but in a way that may
help them grow as well and ultimately
when in doubt listen listen to what
other people have to say but also listen
to what they're experiencing that will
help you shape your feedback more
effectively and I think feedback is
basically only only one way to
strengthen your relationships and Ryan
and I often talk about relationships
because it's one of the the five core
values that we focus on and so Victoria
I would love to send you a copy of our
book minimalism live a meaningful life
that book is the first book we wrote we
wrote it back in 2011 a long time ago
now but we we wrote a second edition
last year and updated basically every
page of that book it's our shortest book
as well as I think 130 pages roughly and
it covers the five values and health
relationships passion growth and
contribution are the five values that we
we hold as core values and relationships
a big part of that is providing feedback
and critiques when when it's appropriate
and we hope that can help you find out
when that is appropriate the good news
is that one just came out on audiobook
as well an updated version of the
audiobooks there was an old version from
five years ago but we updated this
version last year print an e-book so
we'll send you either one of those or if
you want the audiobook version Shona if
you can give her an audible code to
download that book it's read by a very
talented narrator of ours Justin Moloch
he's a really great guy he runs a
podcast called optimal living daily
where sometimes he reads our essays and
other essays from other people on on the
internet like Derek Siver's but he read
the entire book and
he's reading all three of our books
essentials already out there and the
newest one here with minimalism love a
meaningful life is out there Victoria I
hope you find value in that book
especially the relationships chapter it
will help you decide when is the most
appropriate time to to give feedback to
the people you care about well we'd love
to hear what you have to say folks so if
you have a comment about noise or any of
the the caller's questions today
including minimalism tips for how you
handle the noise in your life then leave
us a voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9
of course we'll air our favorite
comments and tips at the end of our next
episode and here's a tip for you make
sure you write down your message before
you call in it will help you articulate
your point and of course it'll increase
your chance of being on the podcast
alright let's move on to our hashtag ask
the minimalists lightning round where we
answer questions from social media we
are on twitter and instagram at the
minimalists and facebook.com slash the
minimalists on all three of those
platforms ryan we try to avoid adding to
the noise because they're looking to be
some really noisy places so we're
constantly asking ourselves before we
send out a tweet or a Facebook post or a
picture is this going to add value to
someone else's life if not then we
delete it we don't we don't send it out
there we share a lot of different things
on social media but we also answer some
questions and so during this lightning
round Ryan and I we do our best to each
answer a question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response and then we'll put the those
responses to the call we call the
minimal Maxim's we'll put those in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like all right our first question is
from Mary how do you deal with
restaurants who have TVs on and loud
music playing at the same time do you
just stay away I don't I guess I have
been to restaurants like that I was just
trying to think they'll like you got TV
blaring
music blaring at the same time like that
is as far as that it just seems like a
crappy environment yeah their TVs are
turned down though right like I think
you're right yeah but there's I was
there this this weekend and it was
packed there's after the cruise game the
Grizz and and and Montana State was out
here for us so really this yes oh man I
miss the big game yeah I was a James bar
and it was this the same sort of
scenario here where the TVs are on
musics playing and everyone around me
was I had I just had to leave we left
early because I couldn't handle it so
what do you do around what's your answer
I typically avoid TV filled restaurants
unless I'm there to watch football
yeah I think my short answer is yes the
first step in turning down the volume is
actually avoiding the noise at the very
least turn your back to the noise I
quite often do that if I'm in a place
and there are TVs everywhere I'll just
make sure that I'm position in the place
where I I can't stare at it because I
find the glowing screens mesmerizing
it's distracting it really is yeah I
mean and then of course by paying
attention to that what am i doing I'm
ignoring the things that are most
important to me like my partner or the
people I'm with our next question is
from Casper
what's the Forgotten value of noise and
static noise isn't always bad I love
going to concerts
lots of noise there yeah I think for me
the I had to think about this question
because I think it's a fair question we
don't often flip questions around on
their head and say was there actually
value here and for me my answer is the
noise helps us appreciate the quiet
there's a David Foster Wallace analogy I
guess if you're whistling Mozart at a
Metallica concert you won't hear it
right because the Metallica concert is
going on
and I think it's the same thing here is
is you you hear all that noise you're
like well I now if I remove myself from
that I can actually appreciate the
quietness and I can go back to whistling
Mozart
Croesus question how do we encourage
friends and family to put away and
silence phones during get-togethers you
know I've been to plenty of
get-togethers where the invite
specifically asks for no phones to be
present during the event the event I
love that idea yeah for me I would just
say for more meaningful get-togethers
leave your phone in the car
suggest a phone free evening and keep a
phone basket near the door or better yet
you could do one of those bowls and put
all the phones in there and then fill
with water and then you freeze them you
can do that there in your game night
okay seriously don't don't go do that
all right next question is from Hudson
what are some practical ways for
silencing mental noise negative thoughts
racing thoughts etc meditate yeah indeed
I love my answer is not as pithy as that
but I would I would just say are your
negative thoughts useful if so take
action if not let go nice whoo this
question is from being conscious yeah
it's interesting how different noise
levels can affect productivity how noisy
do you like your environment while
writing I like being in a coffee shop
it's not the noise though it's the
movement of the people I enjoy for me I
think three words sums up how I like my
writing environment silence reigns
supreme okay let's move on to our added
value portion of the show this is where
we trek amend something that has added
value to our lives recently yeah you
know I think this is very appropriate
and appropriate recommendation for this
episode Mariah and I have a essential
oil diffuser I don't even know the
and of it so I'm not gonna there's not
gonna be a link to the diffuser we have
but if you are someone who yeah has a
lot of distracting things going on in
your household it actually does make you
feel a little calm just like smelling
the frankincense or whatever riot
whatever friend you come up this yeah
whatever fragrance Mariah puts in there
for the day
now you go up this is great I mean it's
really cool it really is call me yeah
like I was really shocked by it like
because it doesn't fill the whole house
it's just like you know it's it's small
one you out where you have in the
bedroom or no it's actually in the
kitchen but I typically will sit at the
counter with my laptop if I am you know
checking social media or doing emails or
writing or whatever and just sitting on
the counter I was it was the other day
we've had it for a couple weeks but it
wasn't till the other day I was sitting
there and I was like what is that
awesome smell I'm like oh yeah that must
be the diffuser yeah and it really was
like a nice like peaceful feeling I mean
it's you know it's not this like magic
bullet but it certainly helps yeah for
sure I've heard pot castles too from Ben
Greenfield and he talks about that a lot
using essential oils and which ones to
use and and when you go to a a steam
room a lot of times they have eucalyptus
and you can because it stays in the air
or the net steam and you can breathe it
in which is pretty awesome for me I have
a few things to recommend a new song
just came out that I spent the weekend
with with Bex we didn't have Ella this
past weekend and I swear we just played
on on repay and it was good John their
fellow Montana has a new song out it's
called love on the weekend I think I
sent you the the b-side he did this like
Josie I have a big shirt song I was on
social media so I was doing the float
tank this on Monday yeah and that song
stuck in my head oh really
big sure but the actual song the love on
the weekend is is a really great song
and speaking of songs I was a band
called brother Cephas you know Seth who
works at the coffee shop that we're
partners in down in in st. Pete and last
time I was was down in st. Pete I went
to a brother Cephas concert he's the
lead singer for that band and they have
an EP and it's called
noise oh wow and so at the end of this
Sean I'd love to that song is a great
song it's it's a little musics heavier
than what I would typically listen to
you know people who know me know I
listen to what are my equivalent of the
theme song that we that we that we play
from Peter Doran is generally Bellis to
either that or 90s hip-hop but noise is
a little bit heavier and and noisy which
is appropriate but it's a great song a
great EP we'll put a link to that in the
show notes as well but we'll play play
out the episode with that at the very
end I already talked about some of our
recommendations with floating and cryo
I shared that whole day trip to Spokane
on on social media so I've been doing
something interesting with the
minimalist account on Instagram doing
this hashtag the minimalist city finds
and so anytime like we go to a new city
or whatever I'll take a picture of the
coffee shop we go to or from in LA and
or in st. Petersburg or Dayton Ohio or
New York City and sharing some different
stuff there so you'll find a bunch of
different things that add value to our
lives if you just search that hashtag on
Instagram the minimalists city fines
Beck and I did we posted like three or
four photos while we were out there and
OH
last thing I'm doing check out my phone
let me show you this Ryan do you notice
anything different about my phone
everything's blacked out blacked out
black and white it out it's grayscale so
let's put a link to the Sean in the show
notes the Atlantic did this like three
or four minute video about by putting
your phone
on greyscale it radically reduces the
the impulsive behavior
mmm they've done some because I mean
pull up and all of the I came all of the
icons are like trying to be the
flashiest like well touch me
this is Mike on you wanna press exactly
yeah and so you can't go to Instagram
now begin and feel it's just kind of
boring like if you pull up an app and
you're like oh great yeah even like the
pictures everything's grayscale and so
I'm doing a holiday phone and media fast
so between Thanksgiving which we're
recording this the day before
Thanksgiving this will be all after
Thanksgiving but between Thanksgiving
and Christmas I am my phone on grayscale
I unfollowed a bunch of just places that
was was I'm based on a low info diet so
radically reduced any news or anything I
had I also removed from my phone a ton
of apps oh no more Twitter I haven't had
Facebook for a long time but no
periscope Instagram I've just deleted a
bunch of apps from my phone and any apps
that I haven't used in the last 30 days
basically are gone and also the
distracting apps any social media is
completely gone from my phone doesn't
mean I won't use social media I just
have to be at a computer at the login do
it more intentionally and like Ryan said
you know checking it once a day is
immune that you may be checking around
five o'clock or whatever I find that to
be far more productive than you know
constantly reaching for my phone the
average person reaches for their phone
over a hundred and fifty times per day
now and ever since moving my phone over
to gray to grayscale there's just not
entertaining anymore especially once I
removed all those supposedly
entertaining apps from for my phone so
I'm gonna try that out for a while
if anyone else wants to try that out and
let us know how it goes for them you
know let me know on social media
eventually I'll get around to to to
seeing that for sure alright let's move
on to right here right now this is where
we get to talk about what's going on in
the lives of the minimalists we've done
a bunch of recent interview some of my
favorites recently I did Louis house he
has a podcast called school of
greatness and may I've gotten more
feedback on that interview then just
about anything that we've done it so
many people really at the end of it he
asked like what if you were to die and
all your websites gone your books are
gone and you can just leave behind three
truths for the world to hear three
things you want to eat you want to
communicate what would they be it was a
great question and I feel like I gave a
really good answer to that so Lewis
Howes it's a great interview also I was
on Tom woods podcast recently Tom woods
as five episodes a week he's a
libertarian and and does and he watched
the documentary with his four kids his
four daughters and really enjoyed the
documentary and the lessons and he's not
necessarily sympathetic with everything
to do with minimalism but found a lot of
value in sharing that the documentary
with his kids and so I spent half an
hour talking to him about that and
libertarianism and I also was on the art
of charm with Jordan Harbinger and
enjoyed that interview for sure we'd get
a bunch of other ones as well you can
just go to the minimalists comm slash
media see a bunch of TV interviews that
Ryan and I have done also some print and
radio interviews other podcast
interviews on there as well also as you
know and this is appropriate for the
Noize episode we don't clutter our
podcasts or our website we don't clutter
them with advertisements but there are a
bunch of ways that you can support the
minimalists and we don't we don't ask
for this often but I figure I throw this
out here for this one you can donate a
few bucks to the minimalists comm /
donate you can or if you can't do that
that's okay you can still share our
podcasts our essays or our TEDx talks
with your friends and family or you
could even just leave us a well thought
out positive review you can review our
podcast on iTunes which helps us reach
more people
you can review our books on Amazon and
you can review our documentary
minimalism a documentary about the
important things you can review that on
IMDB that'd be really helpful or on
Amazon iTunes or Google Play we would
just really thank you for that support
however you're supporting us it's just
listening for sharing if it's reviewing
if it's donating
we really appreciate it what else here
the the holidays they are right around
the corner Ryan and I just did that
gift-giving episode that was one of my
favorite episodes we've done so far it
was number 38 in our feed but we also
have a couple of upcoming things we have
a podcast about the holidays it's coming
up soon so you can subscribe to our
podcast if you don't already check that
out and we have a few essays about the
holiday shopping season that are coming
out and we also have two photo tours
want Ryan did a photo tour of his home
recently I'll be doing one soon if you
want to see a photo tour of my home and
all of these holiday essays you can just
get our email newsletter just go to the
minimalists calm at the top there is a
box that says email newsletter and
decide your email there and we will
never ever send you any spam because
spam is gross
lastly you can hire the minimalist so
Ryan and I are going to do more speaking
gigs next year we we typically do one
speaking gig per quarter and we do a ton
of preparation working on some new
material and we're also working on a new
presentation for old material as well
and so we were sort of the best of both
worlds there and so if you want us to
speak to your University or your
organization you can go to the
minimalists comm a slash speaking we're
gonna try to move that up to about one
speaking gig a month and so that will
start to fill up pretty soon if you're
interested in having us speak to your
university or organization the
minimalists comm a slash speaking we'd
love to we'd love to see you finally
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners hi this is Anna
calling from Brooklyn New York
I loved your show about clutter and kids
and they wanted to add to suggestions
that have really helped me the first is
her relatives who want to buy your kid a
lot of gifts and won't adhere to a one
gift cool to use a little lime which is
something you want something you need
something to read
I used that at Christmas and for my
son's birthday and so he only gets three
gifts and I find that it really helps
and the second tip that I use is to
seven bins or baskets with days of the
week written on them and your child can
only play with the bin which is for the
day of the week it is and not only does
this keep the toys off the floor and the
room ever free it also makes those toys
really special because they only see
them once a week and it ensures that
they actually play with the toys that
they have hi Joshua
and Ryan my name is Jenny and I'm from
Columbia Missouri and I recently found
your podcast your website and I must
thrilled almost 69 year old grandma so
thank you so much for all your doing I
could get two comments I have a
suggestion for other grandparents about
simplifying Christmas I did this several
years ago in terms of grandchildren
so for each grandchild we I designate a
certain amount of money in 2/3 so it
could be 3 $1 bills or 3 $5 bills
whatever your means and the instructions
are that they can take 1/3 and buy
whatever they want just blow it and the
second idea is that or the second
portion is that they say that put into
savings and then the third portion they
must donate pick a charity or
organization to donate because that's
the real meaning of the season the other
comment I want to make has to do with
the I think one of your podcast mentions
what do we do with photos and I have
been I've been searching them and very
emotional about my photos but thanks to
your podcast I now know I can go out and
buy a scanner which I've ordered and I'm
going to learn how to use it and scan my
photos and then I will repurpose or
donate or sell my scanners so that it
doesn't clutter my life hey guys my name
is Krista from here on like to thank you
for another avenue of sharing the
minimalism movement with my family I had
husband who is slowly starting to get on
board he had seen because of my
simplifying he has seen my anxiety
levels greatly decreased I'd also again
to say to this lady said give me another
Avenue to show my twelve-year-old son
who also has anxiety how he can simplify
his life going forward
alright Joe that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine and
if you leave here with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening yeah we'll see you
next time alright here's a track from
brother Cephas
it's called noise
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you